greetings gamers remember me we met in  quite orchard I helped to follow  youngster it seems you need my help  again  do you want my help it's a deal  let me tell you a story it's about a man  worse than most a man who refuses to pay  his debts  well stroke which but perhaps you'd care  to tell me why you meddled in a matter  not yours  you're immortal one date but it's not  what folk about you know died it's not  made of turtley living your life to the  full so it's a curse  you must be careful what you wish for  that there are consequences  you need to get into the vault we break  in each day what we make you wanna can  count them maybe you would see the  variable see how I've wheel there in now  don't [ __ ] this up  [Music]  [Music]